2019 the legislature passed ab168
commonly referred to the public school
restorative justice law
while well intended this law has led to
instances of disruptive and dangerous
situations in schools across the state
it handcuffs School teachers and
administrators leaving them powerless to
address habitually misbehaving all too
often violent students
violence in schools Governor Lombardo in
his State of the State address last
night says he is committed to tackling
this crucial issue and so are those
attending a school security conference
right here in town Joshua peguero the
only TV reporter attending that
conference spoke with Educators and
state officials in attendance and Joshua
what did you find their main focus to be
Brian one of those we spoke to is the
head of school security and matter
Academy a charter school in the East
Valley he says the main focus is to
provide a safe learning environment and
doing that starts at home
we pride ourselves into staying on top
of the security especially at the matter
academies we take it very very seriously
with the way that the buildings are
built with the way that we have the
fencing with 28 years of experience at
Metro under his belt Schmidt is based at
matters High School located near Pecos
and Bonanza he says mental health is a
priority at the school we try to do the
best they can to make sure that the home
life is okay because if the home life is
affecting it affects the school life
Gary sigris is one of the organizers of
this conference he has worked in both
law enforcement and in the classroom in
Ohio and says kids are more often now
resorting to extreme violence to express
their anger what we have today are a lot
of people both children and adults who
are very brittle and they're always
blaming somebody for something bad
that's happened to them sigris who is
also speaking says it's less likely for
a student to attack an educator where
there's a personal connection a skill
they're pushing at this conference there
were other Educators and school resource
officers in attendance even Nevada state
officials the division of emergency
management is actually required by law
to accept and review all School
Emergency Operations plans so being here
to get that information and resources
helps support that mission
now tomorrow there will be a discussion
on Army School staff with concealed
weapons a group will also discuss threat
assessments with the Ohio Attorney
General's office Brian